all right we still rolling Mr D we are
rolling
waiting watching for you to justify my
life remember that song by Madonna from
the 80s it's my favorite madonald song
honestly all right just fine I I granted
your wish of huh I granted your wish of
doing the interview on my sofa what was
my wish oh on the couch on the sofa I
didn't wish I just walked in you're like
a little sex kitten using my Approach I
either got it or I
don't waiting watching for you yes it
was like grungy May West did you did you
stay in the room last night I couldn't
because the guy beat me up I went back
to it later at night but then some guys
came over so I just gave it to them and
I just walked up like 400 in the morning
walking since you don't really need a
room if you're huh you don't really need
a room if you're smoking meth right you
just stay up all night I thought we
agreed the my thing wouldn't be no I'm
just soon I think this C heroin I think
you would find me way more appealing if
I did heroin or something you're kind
person who loves the heroin out no
crystal meth is Crystal crystal meth
addicts are pretty
fun alcoholics are my favorite but do
you think I'm fun you're fun think you
think I'm
very hilarious I mean I think you think
very low sometimes you're hilarious
sometimes you're fun sometimes you're
depressing not too many people do but I
think you think very lowly of me know
that that won't be your advantage in the
afterlife but
anyway waiting
watching for you justify my
love my
love my love see when I started watching
the interviews my voice is very nasal I
had a deeper voice you know girls have
very deep voices you know what I mean MH
California girls have like a weirdly
Manish voice but they're really pretty I
wish had a voice your your voice is
pretty shot right now huh your voice is
your voice is pretty shot right now what
doesn't leave you the briad have leave
Legacy but
still here just read some of these
comments slowly oh my I never want
witchcraft read them read them out loud
I'm a dead girl in the body this Rebecca
is read them out louder I'm going to
take that
phone Everybody Wants To Be
Hollywood you got what it takes more
than anybody you're not doing what I'm
asking I'm trying to read the what it
just pressed the interview I was trying
to get to the comments
just read them slowly methodically one
by
one ladies and gentlemen Rebecca Olson
presents the
Afterparty what a fantastic personality
shout out to Childer
64 she seems like she's made she's a lot
more coherent in this video and it makes
me feel so hopeful she has all potential
of the world within
her who who placed that comment huh who
posted that comment I said Charles St
64 I've shout out to Randy dayberry who
two months ago posted I've said it
before and I'll say it again Rebecca
defines beautiful chaos with a rare
flare of intelligence who just don't
encounter every day love her and truly
wish the best of
everything give say who posted the
comment huh give whoever posted that
comment mention their name I know I'm a
real person Mark
full-blooded very
deep so the phone is right in front of
your face huh the phone is blocking your
face there's no reason for a camera to
be
tone the phone is exactly right in front
of your face so it's like it I'm sorry
[Music]
just oh yeah to this one Anna Hospital
7213 two weeks ago posted I just saw the
inmemoriam video and I immediately
looked for her videos I'm rooting for
her we all were rooting for Rebecca
Rebecca didn't die she was just raped I
thought Mark kid or
anything oh lady
Tron so that was Anna Hospital
7213 shout out to On Demand Amanda who
two months ago wrote I relate so heavy
to the instant flash of thoughts going
through it's disgusting Rebecca's mind I
started singing along with her whenever
she
starts and this one was 17 by Lady
drawn addiction really does manipulate
Rebecca's taste and genius but I'm
really crossing my fingers that she's
growing one day at a time Rebecca I'm
always rooting for you we're all rooting
for you Rebecca see Mark
mhm let's
see at Liz Taylor djn
680 one moment ago posted I I just
watched a few of her videos and an
absolute icon I'd support anything she
does rooting for this legendary Soul
thank you um Liz Taylor thank you
Liz what a
dump oh I have actually read something
before at Kina Brewer I'm happy to all
females too posted 11 days ago I think
it's all females huh I think your
audience is 99% female MH we're witches
Mark we like each
other I wish she could have access to
some fabric and create a runway
show I can only imagine the genius show
she would
produce I never want to see em
get uh Nikki lir wrote two months ago
that's a long one I've never wanted a
person I've seen on the internet to be
just like as much as I do Rebecca I hope
to get clean in therap figure out the
underlying problems and become a
functional person I
that a lot of the videos you do with
Rebecca can be frustrating downright
annoying but I see a bright future if
Rebecca chooses to leave the street life
behind you my your [__] thank you Mark
for being a shorter for them n on it's
she I don't worry about it even though
sometimes I feel like it's enabling am I
enabling you do I enable you huh do I
enable you huh do I enable you you
definitely do not you out a way to give
other people more money than me see give
you 20 bucks you give cor like 200 bucks
and I'm like someone place a question it
but you know
women I see do drugs but he sells me the
drugs and he smokes it and he smokes COC
you don't like my behavior that's fine
just really don't like me which
is if you could talk if you could talk a
little slower we could understand if you
could speak a little more slowly we
could perhaps understand what you're
saying how I speak Mark when you're when
you're high as a [__] kite with no
offense
intended you're not the viewer
here anything you would have said
something but not my place to say it
Mark L like the mark of the beast or
Mark Jacobs which would you rather have
the mark of the beast or be Mark
Jacobs pick
one pick
one calm down huh calm down pick one I'm
asking you a question I don't even know
what the [__] you're asking pick one you
have to the mark of the beast or Mark
Jacobs pick one not a hard
question what did you what did you do
last night Mark I'm asking you a [__]
question I don't know what the [__]
answer to do with drugs I told you I got
a [__] mug last night somebody tried
to shoot me no you cared the mark of the
beast Mar
Jacobs
big one what is Mark of the Beast huh
what is Mark of the Beast what I'm
playing along I'm asking you what mark
of the beast is the mark of the be 666
you don't know what that is I
don't that's all we need to know you
know the devil so the signature of the
devil is
666 would rather have that or be Mar
Jacobs Rebecca you're just you're you're
just I'm sorry your highness never mind
I know I frustrate you so you do
sometimes sometimes you do yeah I'm
sorry I was asking a question never mind
I'll just treat you like an object take
money from you and leave I'd rather this
be transactional too honestly that's all
it really is to
me transaction mediocrity honestly I
would rather not be on the internet
really I really do we can just quit this
right now huh we can just quit I can
take down your videos and we can quit
this I mean eventually if I were decided
to have a career we'll definitely talk
about that yeah I'll take him down huh
I'll take him down I just need the
money I'm just here for the money you
just want me to give you free money and
that's it huh you just want me to give
you free money and that's it no do these
interviews for money I'm not trying to
challenge you here keep the interviews
on I'm just saying you don't like me as
much as when you first met me no I like
you more than I when I first I like you
more than when I first met you I feel
like you like me more when you first met
you you were so polite you know no but I
I've gotten to know you gotten more
comfortable with you yeah you're you're
on a bender right now comfortable you're
on a good one huh you're on a good one
right now so it's you're frustrating am
I I'm really [__] up today I know are
killing me I'm sober as [__] I have I
couldn't get any water today we spent 5
hours walking these [__] alleys where
the huge clothing stores are you know
those really tacky [__] there's great
clothing downtown Alle by the way such a
[__] neighborhood to
gentrify you know I feel like you emblem
ify kind of I don't think what's wrong
with it but the kind of attitude where
people need to be looked down upon
before people can just be made to
acquire wealth you know you need to
exploit poverty for the gain of
attention people are middle class can
look at you know it's not a fetish you
know just broke CU they broke people are
poor want money so I don't want money
I'm just
useless I like you're not you're very
useful and I thank you for that and I'll
share it to the graves I'm supposed to
be in tomorrow or yesterday I
know giv part of a government
conspiracy to sacrifice
me to bring the ultimate witch
back so I named myself
Rebecca The
Comeback when I was born in the season I
was born I was born August 4th and
September John gallan presented a short
fashion show in Paris called The Return
of
Cleopatra which is something I return to
again and again in my exploration of
myself any eventually we have down Mar
need to get a job you know what I mean
but it's been really cute to do you
know really cute to do I'll pay back
whenever you want me to in
dividends so you actually have any plans
to help me with my future or not cuz car
could just help me out with my paperwork
I mean I'm sorry do you actually any
have any plans to help me with my future
Advan in life I'm trying to help you
with your immigration problems I know
which is very nice and sweet get you
someone did offer but I me I was
supposed to meet you at 10:00 this
morning to sign the papers but you
weren't there did you but you didn't
come I was there I was there I drove
around downtown looking for you what
time were you there 10:00 sharp 10 you
so me to be there at 10: what that I was
there at 10 you wer I had tea outside my
studio and I went driving around skid
Road looking for
you the
Kia I'm sorry it was a Jaguar what did
you say the key I had T standing in
front of my studio looking for you while
I drove around skid R looking for
you
you be the drama queen Rebecca while I'm
work
levitating complete retribution complete
retribution I wouldn't smile if I were
you someone talking about how they do
drugs and I do drugs too another one
talking about how I do drugs and so
incredibly
articulate even in the wild interviews
great
vocabulary so much Clarity admidst so
much
self-destruction I can
relate honestly I'm surprised that
rebeca's still alive we
agree
terrified my heart goes after this
tortured Soul such an incredibly smart
creative person
so this person sees me as very
Cooperative
a they don't have to put up with your
[__] though huh they don't have to
put up with your
[__] thank you you want to continue
yeah go ahead huh please continue OMG
Rebecca I have been following your story
for a while I was an addict for a long
time with a boyfriend it was hard AF F
you can do this like Mark I see so much
stinking potential in you girl you are
smart one day just have enough and
that's when the recovery starts my
problem is in drugs Mark it's how you
give a human being who lives on the
street $20
to live on the
street not that I'm saying anything here
I tried to get you housing go ahead and
do it you said that many of time no we
we were there remember there were two
people Mark we've met so many times you
never set a date you just kind of show
up and I mean meet you either way you
you got up and walked away from them
from who oh yeah those people outside
the cor yeah I don't do those I don't do
everybody else onic everyone else on
skido has housing now except for they
all US citizens I can't get well I'm
working on that too I'm working on that
too you couldn't make this more
difficult for me okay Mark let me just
read out to my fans while it comments
read to your fans you asked me to do
this I did I hope Rebecca really pulls
through
this I'm not trying to be demeaning here
this update has made me very emotional
and in tears more than
normal love you sh am hi I'm sh
Deval would you like to come and play
with us
Mark you said want make hate much love
to you
Rebecca
Rebecca's spoken multiple times about
needing gender reassignment surgery to
help her move forward that desire need
is not
pathology hoping for her safety most of
all Define pathology
Mark Define
pathology grab's phone I'm sorry Mark
I'm trying to read my I don't know the
the exact definition of pathology so
you're asking me so I'll find do you
know the definition of
pathology what does pathology the
essential Natures of diseases and
especially the structural and functional
changes produced by
them have you reminded her that she
asked it that she has to transition
maybe she can muster the strength to
actually go to the clinic or maybe you
should be helping her Mark honestly mark
it gets a weird in these videos this
honest I found they keep asking her
about her sexual identity calling her a
man saying she's not a real
woman but at the same time Rebecca is a
woman and deserves her gender identity
surgery I would love to speak with you
about setting a GoFundMe page for Rebeca
to help with her surgery I'm sure a lot
of people would give her I don't think
any doctor in his right mind would Mark
I'm reading that this is a comment this
a comment Mar that's a YouTube comment
this a comment it's a YouTube commenter
okay Mark I'm not a human you Mar if you
walked into a doctor's office right now
no doctor is going to give you any
surgery thank you thank you because I'm
a homeless man no because you're out of
your [__] mind what did I do
why you're so rude to me honestly you're
high as a [__] kite right now I do
drugs Mark I'm sober I literally had
like one hit of MTH yesterday morning
and then I broke my pipe and it got me
through I decided to stay sober like you
what whatever is going on you don't seem
like I'm trying to read I'm trying to
feel better about myself you have a
house and you go to Whole Foods and eat
things I eat from the
trash trying to help you huh I'm trying
to help you you never have
next one [__] you wear me out
okay I'm a trama
Queen conversation with a cross
crossdresser Rebecca don't play the
video please sorry I'm sorry no me
just this is crazy I started watching
rebec's videos backward so seeing her
chocolate speak coherently is just so
crazy you me both baby this is the most
healthier BEC looked I could afford
health if I had wealth [__] thank you
Nic fog
5552 to K F see after watch new videos
is help me to understand why it's hard
for Mark to give up hope for this poor
soul so hold on Hope
Mike get you there
I've seen this interview but watching it
now after the newest one so
heartbreaking look how healthy and clean
and well spoken she is
here this is the last one Rebecca is so
very
mesmerizing you can see the wheels
turning her head she's incredibly
intelligent almost functioning on a
different
plane it's cute I see as a teacher of
philosophy helping us to view the world
and our existence from
Place her eyes alone speak Beauty and
her existence is
Sublime thank you hope of L sm24 AKA Deo
show for the
third looks much better and Lucid to
also when Mark said there's a lot more
beautiful things about you that was
beautiful too Mark really
was this is the most clear-headed I've
seen Rebecca in all of the videos I've
seen she has so much
potential she needs to see these videos
of herself and y'all's dialogue with
each other so
natural when we' started as an interview
it's good to see the bond SL friendship
out that you have all have created I'm
glad Rebecca has you and I hope that she
becomes a successory I hope so too
waiting on you you don't seem very
motivated at fol
here.com this video reminds me of why I
love Rebecca so much what a beautiful
girl for deserving
being I can't wait to see her like this
again thank you to flowers rep
2707 oh my water bottle I'm
sorry oh I feel so sad seeing
Rebecca he's going than
God going
loser she is right though I do speak way
too
fast guys I don't know if you're going
to see this later but anyway Mark's been
really rude lately I'm trying to be
polite about it I ha right I don't know
if you guys are going to see this right
but for ever sees this
footage Becky takes the stage I really
need a job if I wants help me out with a
job you know who needs a roommate you
know what I
mean I'm really trying to hit I've been
stuck downtown please shut
up I've been stuck down time for like
the last two years doing nothing with my
life completely aimless [__] piece of
[__]
Oar I'm always amazed how much knowledge
of movies
actors pop culture
references language thoughts music
fashion and just humor packed in
Rebecca's
head the way the intensity the mystery
the SAS the intellect the understanding
of her sexuality and awareness Rebecca
is
fascinating I hope for wealth so do I
[__] money
money honestly I don't know how I'm the
world he knows so much information and
is only 26 and he lives on the sidewalk
she but that doesn't matter how does she
know all this weird she was from to she
that is a great question what am I a man
or a woman or how do I know so much no
how do you know so much when you don't
you rarely have a phone baseball coach
or [__] we're in laar it's not hard to
pick up a variety and find out what a
movie is I can't understand what you're
saying we are in Los Angeles yeah but
you don't get newspapers you don't get
cell phones you don't get but I can pick
up a variety and time in Beverly Hill
see I can't go to Beverly Hills you
can't even afford to go to Beverly Hills
Mark I can walk in the store and try to
[__] on that thank you for making that
point though I can't understand Dan
you I'm poor your midal class I got to I
can't afford to walk into the store but
I
do me and my friends once we tried to
snatch a bag from Louis Vuitton we
almost got caught but then my friend put
it in one of our other bags and we got
away with it it's always shop but I I I
don't know what you're saying but I'm
talking to them Mark I always used to
shop there's a blooming DS down here on
Santa Monica and I once stole a full
beaded gown I put it under my [__]
dress it just let me walk out with like
$50,000 go tore it up
anyway but you're right I can't afford
you Mar feel you can help me too but you
know you don't look you afford to shop
Beverly Hills Mark I can't understand
you you don't look like you can afford
to shop in Beverly Hills Mark okay can't
even can't you I don't last just pertain
to
me do you shop in Beverly
Hort sorry I'm not trying to be
demeaning here just wondering
do you shop in Beverly Hills I don't
like watching irritates depends what I'm
shopping for huh depends what I'm
shopping for I don't shop a
lot Arthur George socks pretty much hoty
socks justify my I love you Mark I know
you hate me I'm hating you right now of
course you do I don't know what I've
done wrong but you know well you you you
you spent the entire video talking too
fast and with your phone in front of
your face and reading the comments okay
marike I'm sorry you're like in such a
dick how I talk you're in such a dick
mood today it's like what dick mood I
was just reading comments what did I do
no you weren't just reading comments you
were reading them so fast that it's like
I this is a waste of my time what do you
mean I'm going to give you [__] free
money I'm going to get you to sign the
the immigration docs and then I'm going
to Uber you back downtown and I'm like I
get nothing out of it I just wasted an
[__] hour of my day thank you it's
good to know how you really feel about
me baby no I'm like I'm just having this
on camera yesterday you were much better
day before that you were great yeah last
time it was
awful it's got to be the drugs but
you're saying you're you don't like the
sober me this is me sober that's why I
do drugs Mark sober is a fish you ask
the kids downtown that's Cory I always
buy a bag off him right after you
[__] gave me the
money yesterday I didn't just didn't
feel like it thought I'd have a promised
spa day my sh little room I just jerk
off all night [__] listen to music
chain smoke two packs and cigarettes
watch straw Breer as my favorite movie
growing up
Violet my name is violet you ever SE
that movie jawbreaker with rose mcgallen
never saw
it exactly do you know Rose mcgaan is
Mark I think I know the face Charmed
times
up to start the whole heavy wine scene
thing with a
gentle but I'm sorry I speak too quickly
mark it wasn't where we having a
conversation for I when I supposed say
see like if you went to a doctor's
office right now and and he was going to
do your surgery he wouldn't he wouldn't
even be able to understand what you're
for other homeless people I don't know
why you keep looking down yes they would
Mark Mark just like they wouldn't let
you would get a room at the intercon
yeah that makes sense I'm a homeless man
yeah but they just searching for
homeless girls there are other homeless
girls in your videos shouldn't not it's
irritating you personally but R's
character is their own no I don't
understand what you're saying huh I'm
you're not communicating with me hello
Mark what I said was you seem not
appreciate my calendar or the T of my
speaking that's how I speak no the speed
of you're talking you're you're talking
like a mile a minute and mumbling I want
to talk I don't see how that pertains to
you telling me I don't know how to slow
it down right it's cuz you're high I'm
not high I told you I've been sober for
like literally 36 hours first time I've
coming here straight why are you in such
a dick mood today what dick mood what
did I say like everything that's come
out of your mouth is basically you being
a dick to me oh cuz I spoke to cuz I
read the comments out no because every
single you every single thing you've
done since you showed up what has been
just being [__] irr I walked in read
some comments on a
couch play a video by
accident she whatever sorry
Mark whatever try harder to choke on
that dick next time get it all the way
down
Mark
scissors I do cut the back of my top off
immediately back of your top yeah oh
hang on the back you hang on the back a
[Music]
seat you want to C short cut the [__]
knot
off cut the knot off yeah cut the thing
off Mark oh cut it off cut off cut off
there just
rela done there we go here we go again
ni so there you go I got have a
seat if we expecting any Miracles today
it's a very tiring day for
me I got your room what happened to your
back huh I have no clue there's
something on my back your back is all
scraped
up must have been the abuse I was
telling about yesterday tell me what
happened [__] happens is all I can say
sorry it's whatever some guy dragged me
again put the dragon Queen
somehow such a basic [__] today you are
a [__] be worth 300 bucks won't be but
you
know it's not easy being Rebecca is it
huh it's not easy being Rebecca it
really isn't really
isn't somebody on your sounds L not need
to being
bad you can't help it though huh you
can't stop it you can't help it you
can't control yourself I can control
myself markol now would be a great time
to kind of get yourself under control
okay uh under control sounds about right
no but your deportation situation yeah
which will be solv the [__] Mark it's
not hard for a to not get deported no
but like like they she Carla the
immigration attorney can't even process
your paperwork because you won't give
her your parents' names I don't want
to I'll be
fine I'll walk my own way I'm so used to
being alone well no I mean you got
people trying to help you do I yes you
do who me and Carla and oh Carla from
the CIA Carla immigration attorney CIA
coincidence Mark you're being played
here I'm sorry I'm not sorry a lot of
people see you and it's fine to think
you um have an entitlement to anything
in life but you know a little respect
and tone goes a long way I'm just trying
to help you out and I really would
accept your help as long as you were
actually offering it versus I'm just
using words any what I want you to do
Mark is I want you to take me shopping
and take me to Hollywood and get me a
room at the Best Western
motel it's a motel
Mark can you do that for me baby
um you don't seem too busy today no I'm
very busy today it's Christmas Eve oh is
it Christmas Eve mhm take me to weo
please I hate
Christmas I'll take you to West
Hollywood thank you well I got the hotel
room too that I need add I'll get you a
phone and I'll get you another hotel
room it's getting tiring though like the
last the last phone I got you had the
immigration Attorney's phone number on
it so you could help yourself a little
bit but you lost that phone
I'm very sick you're sick with what the
plastic cancer
stuff let's call it a a
fumble that's why I don't like being not
in control we talk about control earlier
all this plastic my ears my feet this
[__] oh my God reminds me like when
they used to involve asan Egyptians but
any makes you feel like I'm completely
lobotomized brain
dead your ears bugging you again it bugs
me every time we see each other Mark I
think you know us says a pattern I'm
trying to take you to a doctor but you
you run off Mark you haven't taken me
yet you want to take me you can take me
anytime let's see if they're open on
Christmas Eve huh let's see if they're
open on Christmas Eve I keep saying I'm
open to it you keep just leaving me it's
like the other day I don't leave you no
when you we out Monica we filmed for 2
hours you talked so much [__] to me you
just 20 bucks and just left be stranded
in Sant Monica I could right CU you
because you were so
abusive I'm surprised I gave you 20
bucks
you you you needed to calm down from
from whatever you a
spanking you deserved a spanking but I'm
not I'm not into
SP you were out of control that day huh
you were out of control that day I I I
wouldn't even use that video if I used
that video you would lose all your fans
I really wouldn't not that you would
know but anyway just talk they don't see
that side make me feel worse honestly
I'm sorry just give me if it worth we
already having a [__] enough day no I'm
trying to help you Mark can help
me you used to say something to me when
I was a kid right as all as she was you
don't just say you love me you prove it
actions so you don't want you don't want
the help with the deportation situation
I keep saying I want the help don't
speak for me Mark I got you a phone with
her phone number on it she needs some
information from you Mark oh my godness
mhm so you you just told me that you
don't want to give her the information
that she needs I'm having a really bad
morning please just
chill
you're a challenge huh you are a
challenge I definitely am I'm not easy
to handle mm- so what happened to you
last night I got mugged and dragged by
some guy he stole my purse and dragged
me and Tred to rape me it happens to me
all the time I'm very susceptible to
rape and attack why do you hang out on
the streets because I'm homeless Mark
what the [__] no I I got you kind
questions that I'm sorry
if if you why don't you enjoy your life
why don't you find a way to smile more
and stop try find way to put down I
smile a lot but you you freak me out I
love my life I smile all the time you
love this life I love my life I don't
love this life it
is what we call a roadblock an obstacle
I'll use it to my advantage because I
know how to I'm a lot smarter than you
think I am and there's quite a bit more
going on here than you would dare to
concede to Mark trust me you will regret
a lot of decisions you made we know this
it's fun with us we're just a bunch of
give give me an example of a decision I
might regret flaming
[__]
fish fish
Mark Fish
Market what are you doing ew you were
there I'll do my scientific Bard I think
you're losing your
mind gladly she said I'll do anything
not to grow up like you I'll do anything
to lose my mind that's what they used to
call witches insane people any everyone
else seems to love it Mark so thank you
for being my one true critic Mr
D hilarity
ensues so do you want another phone I
would love another phone would you like
Carlos would you like the immigration
Attorney's phone yes I would Mark okay
good I wish you luck on that
conversation
say all right we
good yeah and my soul for $300 cash
[Music]
[__]
that